as we begin today we want to acknowledge
the place in which we are gathered is
situated on treaty land steeped in rich
indigenous history
this land is the traditional territory
of the anishinaabeg nation specifically
the chippewa tri-council nations
comprised of the beausoleil first
nations
chippewas of rama first nations and
chippewas of georgina island first
nation
this acknowledged acknowledgment shows
respect for how indigenous people have
shaped ontario and reminds us of our
important connection to this land where
we learn
work and heal
let us reflect on what each of us can do
to reconcile the past and work toward
act together toward a shared more just
future i would also like to recognize
that today marks the two-year
anniversary since the first covid19 case
was confirmed in ontario
at that time none of us knew the impact
or could predict the longevity of the
pandemic
rvh like all hospitals across the
province had to quickly react and pivot
to the ever-changing environment
sourcing ppe reducing surgical volumes
creating critical care capacity while
never ever losing focus on the most
important thing
providing safe
quality patient care
sadly rvh had the first covet related
patient death in the province and it
really made us aware that we were in for
a long and tough fight
i want to thank everyone at rvh for
their perseverance commitment and
willingness to rise up to this challenge
we've learned many lessons along the way
and rvh will continue to be here for the
communities we serve
and while we have turned the corner on
our battle our thoughts go out to the
people of ukraine who are facing such a
dark and troubling time
to begin today's announcement i would
like to welcome a number of friends
joining us today the premier of ontario
doug ford welcome back premier ford
deputy premier and minister of health uh
the honorable christine elliott
attorney general and mpp for barry
springwater oramadante the honorable
doug downey
mpp berry innisfil andrea kanjin
the mayor of the town of innisfil and
deputy warden county of simcoe lynn
dolan
doug frost first vice chair of the rbh
board of directors and we're also joined
today by michael gleason second vice
chair of the board of directors and
marianne frith who co-chairs the moments
matter capital campaign welcome everyone
[Applause]
i want to begin today by thanking you
premier ford sorry my back is to you
and your government
for the outstanding support over the
past two years provincial funding
enabled rvh to open 140 additional beds
including a 70 bed field hospital that
the premier toured last july
we converted almost 40 critical care
spaces we hired more than 300 staff
including nurses cleaners screeners and
respiratory therapists
your support insured rbh could not only
safely care for people from across this
region during the pandemic but also
accept the transfer of more than 250
patients from the overburdened gta
hospitals
of course royal vic has a very proud
history of caring for simcoe muskoka in
fact this year we celebrate our 125th
anniversary
a century and a quarter of always being
here for the people of our region 125
years of care and compassion and
constant growth to meet the needs of our
growing region
25 years ago rvh began a new chapter
with a brand new hospital here on
georgian drive but it was full almost
the moment it opened in 2012 we opened
an expansion phase one expansion
including the regional cancer center and
more than 100 beds we called it phase
one because we always knew that there
must be a phase two which would include
a major expansion here at the north
campus along with the development of a
new south campus
a second hospital in simcoe muskoka
county has long been one of rvh's
strategic goals
after a three-year comprehensive search
an unprecedented community consultation
during which we logged 63 500
interactions last fall rvh announced the
location of its new south campus at
innisfil beach and young street
the south campus will open in 10 years
as an outpatient health hub evolving to
a full service hospital in 20 years
seeing almost 350 000 patients each year
rvh's one system two site model means
the north and the south campus will be
integrated not interdependent for
instance if a patient gets a heart test
at the south campus they'll receive
their advanced cardiac procedure here at
the north campus you can see why the
expansion must proceed together
we know the population of south simcoe
county is going to double over the next
couple of decades and if the pandemic
has taught us anything it's that we must
ensure we have enough beds and critical
care spaces to meet the needs of our
exploding population
actually there's nothing more important
when than your health and that of your
loved ones your parent is sick your
child suffers a broken bone you need a
diagnosis of a troubling health issue
you want to get the care you need as
quickly and as close to home as possible
frankly nothing else matters that's why
rvhs expansion will plan to do we're
going to double the size of this
facility we're going to add more
operating rooms beds specialized
services here at the north and we're
going to build a new hospital in
annisville all of these features will
ensure accessible quality health care
for generations to come
our ambitious plan has received
outstanding support from attorney
general downey and mpp kanjin along with
the town of innisfil the city of barrie
auroma dante and spring water
thousands of community members told us
you've chosen the right location for the
south campus now please build it as soon
as possible the need is now
in fact
premier ford when you visited rvh last
summer and we took the opportunity to
tell you a bit about our capital plan
your response was simply
let's get it done
well that's become our mantra and i have
to tell you premier ford i've probably
quoted you a few times since then
now we know the timelines to build a
hospital are long and complex but we're
so pleased to welcome you here today
with news about how your government will
accelerate development of the south
campus get shovels in the ground faster
and bring health care
and jobs to simcoe county sooner
premier welcome back to rvh
now it's my honor to welcome attorney
general doug downey mpp for barry
springwater ormodonte the honorable doc
downey to come to the podium doug
thank you so much janice for that
wonderful introduction and and for
highlighting some of the ways that our
government and our premier have shown
leadership i can't tell you how great it
is to have the minister of health and
deputy premier and the premier in this
space at rvh which is a heart of simcoe
county it's a place where we're
providing frontline care and i want to
thank the people in the back who are
doing the actual frontline care and it's
great it's just great to have the the
news that we're about to hear and i'm
going to be brief because we want to get
to the good stuff but i want to say one
thing
one thing about the character of our
government and the character of our
leadership in our government both
minister elliot and my my friend andrea
canjon a colleague from barry innisfil
we've talked with us a lot but the
leadership that our premier has shown
over over the years
through a pandemic that's when you get
the real result of an individual is
through a crisis but not only have we
made our way through this time we've
also been able to
build and expand about infrastructure
health care because the premier
understands what ontarians need and he
understands that we need to deliver it
because nobody else will so i will stop
there i'm so thrilled that you're here
premier and i'll welcome you to the
podium thank you
well
first of all
thank you so much doug and and janice
thank you and i i do remember that we
were in the hallway and you showed me
the picture and let's get it done and
that's exactly what you did
so on on behalf first first of all good
afternoon everyone i just want to thank
uh the champions as i call them thank
you for everything you've done
throughout this pandemic
and uh on behalf of uh minister downey
minister elliott and mpp andrea kanjin
let me start by thanking again the staff
here all the staff at royal victoria
regional health center
the doctors nurses
and support staff have given their all
to take care of us when we need it most
and we're absolutely so grateful for
everything you do
i also
want to thank jana scott who leads a
truly world-class team here
and after 17 years at royal victoria
regional health center janice is
entering a well-earned retirement this
june but you know janice i don't know if
you'll ever retire you'll find something
else because just just an incredible
person and she's certainly left her
legacy here at rvh
friends after two very long years we've
come so far
because of the sacrifices made by
ontarians and the amazing care provided
by our health care heroes we've been
able to safely and cautiously reopen our
province
but looking back we know that ontario
wasn't ready when the pandemic hit us
and you're right it's two years
today i think the world health
organization
announced this pandemic now now looking
ahead
we can be confident that ontario is
better prepared for the future
we're producing more of the masks
gowns gloves goggles face shields right
here at home
because of our ambitious plan that's
building ontario we're adding thousands
of hospital and long-term care beds with
the support of our government's historic
funding
towns like barry and innisfil are
attracting more doctors nurses and
personal support workers to take care of
patients
but we can do more to build a stronger
and more resilient health system
and today our government is continuing
to do so right here in simcoe county
because we're investing 2.5 million
dollars to support the planning of royal
victoria's new south campus health hub
this is the first step of building a new
health hub to better serve the people of
simcoe county
the hub will provide urgent care
services and day surgeries
providing faster access to procedures in
relieving capacity on the hospital's
emergency department
this redevelopment will put patients
first and ensure they can receive high
quality
timely care when they need it
it will bring more critical healthcare
infrastructure to a growing population
that needs it desperately
and i need to give a huge huge shout out
to mayor lynn dolan of veniceville who
is here with us today thank you lynn for
everything you're doing
you know lynn knew that the people of
simcoe county needed more hospital
capacity and there was no time to wait
so she took the initiative and requested
an mzo to make sure we could get shovels
in the ground with no delay
and as always we listen to our municipal
partners
because they know best what's happening
in their communities and how we as a
province can help
so again thank you to mayor dolan mpp
andrea kangen minister downey and
minister elliot who worked so hard to
deliver this for the people of simcoe
my friends in burying across ontario
were making good on our promise to end
hallway healthcare with a historic and
these are big big numbers with a
historic 30.2
billion with a b billion dollars
invested over the next 10 years to
renovate and expand hospitals around the
province
these are not band-aid solutions we're
getting shovels in the ground and
investing for a stronger future for
generations to come
our province has come so far and we
can't afford to go back to the politics
of no
instead
your government is saying yes
yes to building modern hospitals yes to
investing in our communities and yes to
building a stronger and more resilient
province friends let's say yes to a
better and brighter future that the
people of ontario deserve
thank you and god bless the people of
ontario now i'll hand it over to the
champion herself mayor dolan
[Applause]
thank you so very much premier ford uh
this is such a game changer for the town
of veniceville and i have to tell you
that when we found out about the mzo i
texted
the premier and i said we would so love
for you to be in our community to
announce this 60 seconds later my phone
rang this is doug ford i'd love to come
to innisfil so thank you so much for
being here with us today south simcoe is
growing so rapidly and we must plan to
meet the evolving healthcare needs that
come with that growth
in israel town council recognizes that
as we grow it is important to ensure
that additional health services are
readily available to our community which
is why we work so closely with rvh to
request a ministerial zoning order
from the minister of municipal affairs
and housing and if you would please pass
on my thanks to minister clark uh for
for seeing our vision and doing that
work for us we are excited to work
closely with our partners at royal
victoria regional health center as they
develop this south campus site in the
heart of veniceville on behalf of
veniceville citizens i'd like to thank
premier ford
deputy premier elliott minister clark
barry innesville mpp andre canton and to
steal one of the premier's lines she is
an absolute champion for the people of
veniceville thank you
and of course our neighbor the attorney
general as well for all of your support
in ensuring that we can move forward
with developing this critical
infrastructure for our community
the issuance of this mzo will accelerate
the creation of a new south campus
health hub right in innisfil and we are
committed to enabling the health
wellness and resilience of our community
not only will the south campus address
the urgent need for health care in
innisfil and simcoe county it will also
generate approximately 3
000 permanent jobs and will help
facilitate additional economic growth
for our town this is an incredible
moment for innersville
and i'm excited to see how the next two
decades will unfold as the south campus
grows into a full-service hospital for
our community thank you
i'll now invite uh vice chair doug frost
to the podium
[Applause]
thank
you grab my glasses
it's the problem with wearing glasses
there we are
so thank you premier ford thank you for
being here today uh thank you minister
elliot attorney general downey
uh mpp kanjin you've brought us
incredibly good news and it's wonderful
to have you in here in person today
at rvh we're focused on bringing quality
accessible
healthcare closer to home
we've done it with regional cancer care
and more recently we've done it with our
cardiac expansion
and make no mistake the proposed north
campus expansion and the south campus
development in innisville
will completely transform health care
for all residents of this area
today's announcement of a two and a half
million dollar planning grant and the
approval of the minister's zoning order
provides certainty that a hospital can
be built on our nsfil site
it will accelerate our plans
and allow rvh to get on with the
detailed site planning and further
community consultation
so rvh intends to submit stage one of
its capital plan in early april
and you know we'll be knocking on your
doors again anxious to secure those
necessary approvals to keep this project
moving forward
so attorney general downey and mpp
kanjin thank you again for the strong
ongoing advocacy on behalf of your
constituents
and again
especially to jenna scott who really has
made the south campus a priority over
her eight over her 17 years here at rvh
so how fitting is it that we're able to
celebrate this moment
as you prepare for your retirement later
this spring thank you janice
so in healthcare we must see beyond the
demands of today we have to look a
decade in advance
it's that kind of foresight that really
builds great communities
so it's for that community of the future
that we say thank you
thank you for your trust in rvh
thank you for seeing the future
and thank you for imagining the
possibilities
so i'll now turn it back to premier ford
to address the same questions
thank you
[Applause]
we'll now take questions from the media
if those with questions could please
form a line behind me at the microphone
it'll be one question and one follow-up
per reporter okay
hi premier ford hi how are you good
shane mcdonald from berry advance yes
i was just speaking with some people who
are
immunocompromised and they expressed
some concerns about
the dropping of the mass mandate and
you know going out in public into a
restaurant
and i'm wondering what you would say to
those people about you know the way
forward uh as we begin to get out of
this pandemic hopefully well i'd say
keep your mask on uh then that's gonna
be an option that's the direction
uh we received from from dr moore
and as you see right across the country
i think bc announced they're dropping it
today they just announced it and bang
dropped it and we're one of the last
jurisdictions in north america
to be doing this and i've always been
cautious as i say
i've been accused of being the most
cautious and i have no problem with
being the most cautious and we're going
to continue to be cautious so anyone who
wants to wear a mask i encourage you to
wear a mask
and just as a follow-up um
can you tell me a bit about
why you guys chose innisfil for this new
hospital there's you know lots of places
want a new hospital right so what it is
about innisfil well first of all we're
building new hospitals the lakes of
which this country has never seen before
we're putting 30.2 billion dollars of
investments and renovating and building
hospitals right across the uh right
across ontario and i gotta i'll talk
specifically about barry and in innisfil
number one they're beautiful uh barry is
a beautiful city minnesville is a
beautiful town and people are flocking
here and i encourage everyone and this
is when i when i say mayor dolan's a
champion
go online and look under the orbit
you've never seen anything like it it's
absolutely spectacular more and more
people after this pandemic want to get
out of the city
and if they have to commute they're
putting a go train stop there as well so
they'll be able to hop on and zip into
toronto if they need to
uh it's just a incredible
area and it's a green area and more and
more people are moving up here of all
different ages it's absolutely booming
uh barry in in innisfil and i just want
to again thank
thank uh the mayor for the incredible
job she's done uh i want to thank her
for for requesting the mzo and keep
requesting those ms because we need
housing we're in desperate need of
housing for everyone we need affordable
housing for everyone and more and more
people
are moving out of the out of the
jurisdiction of toronto and gta
and we're building the infrastructure
and we're building the roads and we're
building bridges and highways the 413 is
absolutely critical the bradford bypass
is absolutely critical for the growth
we're going to see
folks we're going to see 200 000 more
people move into our province uh every
single year that is that is a staggering
amount but it's a good thing because
we're short 338 000 people to fill the
fill the jobs right now and with our
expansion of broadband too we're
spending 4.2 billion dollars
throughout the province so everyone can
have high-speed uh internet connection
and that is absolutely critical and it
just allows people to work from home too
and
i i'm excited i'm excited about the
future thank you
uh hi premiere sean gibson from
verytoday.com hey john how are you not
too bad thank you um
the the south campus was talked about
long before uh coved came about how
important was it to fast track the
funding for this hospital because of
covet how did covert make you realize
that healthcare was important to
contribute to the area yeah and you know
before i pass it over to the minister
health which has just been my right-hand
person and i'm so grateful for all the
work uh minister elliot has has done
uh we we have to move speed to market on
everything on housing
on on
making sure we have the hospitals built
schools built we're spending 148 billion
dollars on infrastructure and for 15
years of the previous government they
ignored it they ignored hospitals
schools
infrastructure
transportation systems we're building
phenomenal subway systems in
toronto gta we're expanding uh go trains
to a 260 billion dollars so we can
connect people
i'm a business person i i can't go
through government hurdles and all the
barriers and everything let's get it
done
as i said to janus get it done and uh
we're moving at a rapid speed and i just
want to thank everyone
in ontario in all sectors for for
helping out very few jurisdictions in
north america are experiencing the
growth uh the economic growth well they
just announced yesterday a hundred and
was a 198 000 jobs were created
those are like staggering numbers
uh in in in one month
so
thank you to the people of ontario
that's that's what i can say they get
the credit and i'll pass it over to the
minister of health because
we have to tell you she was instrumental
in pushing the file forward in the 30.2
billion dollars and just a true leader
well we did need to move very quickly
when the pandemic started several years
ago because we were behind in many
things one we had a warehouse of expired
ppe so we had to move quickly on that we
also didn't have a comprehensive testing
system or laboratory system so we had to
put all of that together it was like
building a plane as you're flying it
literally and we also were way behind in
terms of the number of beds available in
our hospitals we've spent over 5 billion
dollars and with that we've created over
3 100 additional beds which we certainly
needed at the peak of the pandemic to
make sure that we could house all of our
patients and hospitalize them within
ontario
we're also able to help
with patients from manitoba as well
during the course of the pandemic but
these beds and the beds that are going
to be built here ultimately when the
hospital in innisfil becomes a
full-service hospital we really need to
make sure that we can take care of all
of the people
in ontario wherever they live but this
was a massive project as the premier
indicated we are building other
hospitals as well
to make sure that we can catch up to
make sure that we can have the number of
beds both medical surgical beds as well
as intensive care beds
to meet the needs of patients both
during the pandemic and now of course
that we're working on all of the
surgeries and procedures that had to be
postponed because of covet so we are
going to continue to uh need and use
those bets
and just my follow-up to premiere
not to bring up a hot topic that is
usually for you but a lot of the times
you've been open about heading to your
college and you come through this way
over the last many years uh has the rvh
ever
meant anything you in your family or do
you have you ever had any personal
experiences with the rvh yeah i think
thank god we we didn't ever have to rush
to the the hospital and it's not a hot
topic for me
i'll be very frank i work 24 7. it
drives my wife absolutely crazy but i
get on that phone and i don't stop but
that's part of the job and we're going
to continue working all the way right up
to the election on june the second and
and moving forward after that i just
i don't
i don't i don't i don't like just
sitting back and relaxing i like working
but uh that's it last question thank you
hey jamie hi mr premier um
mr premier the mass mandate coming down
of course he announced it school boards
um some school boards are going to defy
it some school boards said they were
going were disappointed and wanted to
extend it a few weeks some school boards
have even backtracked on their statement
what they said today
what are you going to tell school boards
about the masked mandate they want
something a little different than what
you're offering or you're telling them
well let me let me be very clear to the
school boards they aren't medical
experts
the chief medical officer is the expert
and he is he's
done his due diligence he's consulted
with other medical officers maybe a dr
deville or dr etches in ottawa he
doesn't make these decisions lightly uh
but our expectations to the school
boards
uh and to the exception of the parents
that want their kids to put mass on
follow the direction of the chief
medical officer plain and simple that's
what we expect
and hopefully they'll they'll do that
if i follow up on that question do i
wreck my second question yes
what do if they don't uh i i guess you
have uh
um
a method to deal with that but going to
my second question
um
daylight savings times this weekend you
passed a bill to
get away with uh get rid of daylight
savings time provisioning some other
regions uh join you they haven't
are you going to stick with daylight
saving time or are you going to uh go
alone and and no i think i think we
eventually stick with the daylight
savings time and uh move you know just
be like the rest of the
north america
right but it's nice to have those long
days now and it's nice to get out there
and and as we go through the the summer
we can spend more time outside and
and
that's what i look forward to spending
time with
the families and and friends uh folks we
just we we have to be very very cautious
but we we have to move forward on it
like people are tired they want to get
back to their normal lives and
and uh yes we've been cautious but we
need to move forward and we'll always be
cautious i just want to is this it so i
just want to wrap up to the people of
barry and
i want to thank you for everything
you've done
you won't find two better
representatives to represent
your opinions and your voice down at
queen's park than andrea canjon and doug
downey you're well represented here you
also have caroline mal rooney in the in
the region
and i can assure you have a very very
loud voice there they're true leaders
and we look forward to your support on
june the second for all three of them so
thank you god bless have a very safe
weekend everyone thank you